the Beatles sang the money can't buy you
love but might it make you happier
a new study compared wealth and
well-being around the world each circle
represents a country size approximately
by its population the red circle show
countries where happiness has moved in
the opposite direction to GDP the blue
circle show countries where happiness
and GDP have moved in the same direction
they go from richer to poorer what about
happiness on a scale from zero to ten
where would you place your life
satisfaction right now that question was
asked of thousands of people around the
world and surprisingly the rich in the
country the happier it is that makes
Europeans the most gleeful Africans the
most miserable but there's a snag
overall in about a third of countries
happiness has moved in the opposite
direction two income countries don't
always get happier as they get richer in
America people are less happy despite a
growing economy and in the UAE happiness
is risen despite falling wealth take the
world's two most populous places incomes
in both India and China have about
doubled in 10 years but levels of
happiness have diverged working out
precisely why we'll keep wonks happy for
years
you